To prevent unauthorized use of a device,
a user can use passcode or touch ID.
Touch ID is the fingerprint
sensing system
that makes secure access to
the device faster and easier.
That is,
it provides a degree of convenience.
By setting up a device passcode,
the user automatically
enables data protection.
iOS supports four digit and
arbitrary length alphanumeric passcodes.
To further discourage brute
force passcode attacks,
the iOS interface enforces
escalating time delays
after the entry of an invalid
passcode at the last screen.
Users can choose to have
the device automatically waived if
the passcode is entered incorrectly
after ten consecutive attempts.